>>> THE SENATE WILL BE BACK IN
SESSION THIS WEEK AFTER A MONTH
LONG RECESS WITH JUST OVER TWO
MONTHS UNTIL MIDTERM
ELECTIONS,THERE ARE SEVERAL BIG
TICKET ITEMS ON THE AGENDA.
WE'RE JOINED FROM CAPITOL HILL.
DANIELLA, WHAT ARE THEY EXPECTED
TO START ON WITH THIS WEEK?
>> SARA, LAWMAKERS HAVE BEEN
GONE THE ENTIRE MONTH OF AUGUST,
SPENDING TIME IN THEIR HOME
STATES, MEETING CONSTITUENTS BUT
NOW THE SENATE IS GOING TO BE
BACK ON TUESDAY AFTER THIS LABOR
DAY WEEKEND AND THE FIRST THING
THEY'RE GOING TO TACKLE, SARA,
IS GOVERNMENT FUNDING.
OF COURSE, GOVERNMENT FUNDING
RUNS OUT SEPTEMBER 30th AT
MIDNIGHT.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS DON'T
WANT A GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN SO
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO WORK ON
SOME SORT OF SHORT-TERM FUNDING
RESOLUTION BEFORE THEN TO AVOID
A GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
ADDITIONALLY, THE SENATE IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TRYING TO
CONFIRM FEDERAL JUDGES NOMINATED
BY PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
DEMOCRATS CAN DO THAT ALONG
PARTY LINES WITHOUT ANY
REPUBLICAN SUPPORT.
THEY'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT.
LASTLY, THERE'S BEEN MOMENTUM TO
TRY TO PUT LEGISLATION TO CODIFY
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE INTO FEDERAL
LAW.
CHUCK SCHUMER HAS NOT YET SAID
WHEN HE PLANS TO DO THAT.
OF COURSE, THAT HAS BECOME A
PRIORITY IN THE WAKE OF THE
SUPREME COURT OVERTURNING ROE V.
WADE.
DEMOCRATS WANTING TO CODIFY
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE AND DEMOCRATS
WANTING TO PUT SOME REPUBLICANS
ON THE RECORD FOR THAT TOUGH
VOTE, ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE
FACING TOUGH RE-ELECTION RACES
SUCH AS RON JOHNSON IN
WISCONSIN.
WE EXPECT THOSE BIG TICKET ITEMS
ON TUESDAY, AND A WEEK AFTER,
THE HOUSE IS BACK IN SESSION AS
WELL.
THE PRIORITY BEING, SARA, THAT
THESE LAWMAKERS WANT TO GO BACK
TO THEIR HOME STATES, ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN THE SENATE FACING TOUGH
MIDTERM RACES AND ALL HOUSE
MEMBERS UP IN THE MIDTERMS SO
THEY CAN CAMPAIGN AND MEET WITH
CONSTITUENTS.
SO THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO GET
THIS DONE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
SO THEY CAN GO TO THEIR HOME
STATES.
>> DANIELLA, LOTS GOING ON ON
THE HILL COMING UP THIS WEEK.
THANKS SO MUCH.
>>> WITH ME NOW IS DAVID, CNN
POLITICAL COMMENTATOR AND SENIOR
STAFF EDITOR FOR "NEW YORK
TIMES" OPINION.
THANK YOU BOTH, BY THE WAY, FOR
COMING ON ON THIS SUNDAY, ON A
HOLIDAY WEEKEND.
WE APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON.
BIDEN IS RETURNING TO THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL TOMORROW HEADING
TO KEY MIDTERM STATES LIKE
WISCONSIN AND PENNSYLVANIA.
THIS HAS COME AFTER HIS REALLY
FIERY, PROBABLY THE MOST FIERY
SPEECH, IF I DARE TO SAY, WHERE
HE CALLED OUT MAGA REPUBLICANS
AND WARNED THAT EXTREMISM, THE
TRUMP MOVEMENT ITSELF IS A
DIRECT THROAT DEMOCRACY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS PIVOT
FOR BIDEN?
DO YOU SEE IT AS A PIVOT?
>> IN A SENSE, SARA, IT IS A
PIVOT.
I THINK THAT SPEECH WAS
SOMETHING THE DEMOCRATIC BASE
WAS LOOKING FOR AS A WAY TO SORT
OF CLEAR THE DECKS AND CLEAR THE
AIR AND HAVE THE PRESIDENT STATE
IN UNCERTAIN TERMS HE SEES THERE
ARE THREATS TO DEMOCRACY ON THE
HORIZON.
I DO THINK IT WILL WAKE UP THE
DEMOCRATIC BASE AS WE HEAD INTO
THE GENERAL ELECTION.
ON THE OTHER HAND, I DO THINK
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE HAVE SEEN
SOME OF THAT RHETORIC, INCLUDING
HIS USE OF THE WORD SEMIFASCIST
BEFORE THE SPEECH, NOT DURING
THE SPEECH, IT'S GOING TO MAKE
SOME WORK FOR HIM TO DO AS HE
TRIES TO PERSUADE THE VOTERS
BETWEEN THE 45-YARD-LINE,
SUBURBAN VOTERS, VOTERS IN
PHILADELPHIA, ET CETERA, THAT
HELPED HIM IN 2020 AND NOW HE'LL
HAVE TO CONVINCE TO STAY WITH
DEMOCRATS, NOT SWITCH HORSES AND
GO BACK TO REPUBLICANS WHERE
MORE OF THEM WERE IN 2016.
DEMOCRATS HAVE THE WIND AT THEIR
BACK HERE.
BUT IT'S STILL A TOUGH MIDTERM
YEAR FOR THE PARTY THAT HAS THE
WHITE HOUSE AND BOTH HOUSES OF
CONGRESS.
>> DAVID, YOU MENTIONED THE WORD
SEMI-FASCISM AND CONSERVATIVES
HAVE JUMPED ON THAT, ESPECIALLY
THE RIGHT-WING MEDIA.
YOU KNOW, THIS WORD IS SUCH A
TOUCHSTONE AND IT CAN BE
POLARIZING.
AS HE DESCRIBED SOME OF THE
EX-PRESIDENTS MOST LOYAL
SUPPORTERS.
HE MADE NO BONES ABOUT IT.
TIM, DOES BIDEN NEED TO BE
CAREFUL AT ALL HERE USING THIS
KIND OF LANGUAGE THAT, LOOK, A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND THERE ARE SOME
MODERATE REPUBLICANS THAT DO
THINK THAT'S WHERE THE COUNTRY
IS HEADED, HOWEVER, WE REMEMBER
THE WHOLE THING THAT HAPPENED TO
HILLARY CLINTON WHEN SHE USED
THE TERM BASKET OF DEPLORABLES.
HOW DOES HE WALK THIS LINE OR
DOES HE NEED TO AT THIS POINT
CONSIDERING WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6th?
>> THERE ARE MOMENTS IN OUR
HISTORY WHEN OUR HEAD OF STATE
HAS TO EXPLAIN THE STAKES WE
FACE.
THOSE MOMENTS DON'T COME OFTEN
BUT THEY DO COME.
AND I THINK IN LATER YEARS,
HISTORIANS WILL LOOK BACK AT
THIS MOMENT AND SAY THIS WAS A
TIME FOR THE PRESIDENT TO MAKE
CLEAR WHAT THE STAKES ARE, NOT
ONLY IN THIS MIDTERM BUT IN THE
TWO YEARS UNTIL THE NEXT
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
DOES HE NEED TO BE CAREFUL?
HE NEEDS TO BE CAREFUL TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT NOT ALL REPUBLICANS
FIT IN HIS BASKET OF
AUTHORITARIAN DEPLORABLES.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES FOR
HILLARY CLINTON WAS THAT THIS
COMMENT OF HERS WAS -- SEEMED AS
IF IT MEANT ALL TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
AND I THINK WHAT THE PRESIDENT
THIS TIME WAS TRYING TO MAKE
CLEAR IS THAT HE'S ONLY TALKING
ABOUT SOME REPUBLICANS.
AS LONG AS HE HITS THAT NOTE,
HE'S SPEAKING THE SAME WAY AS
LIZ CHENEY.
AND OTHER REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DIRECTION THEIR PARTY HAS TAKEN.
>>.
>> YOU DID MENTION THE WHOLE
THING ABOUT SAYING SOME
REPUBLICANS.
HE DID THAT IN HIS SPEECH MORE
THAN ONCE, TRYING TO MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION.
WE DID ACTUALLY HEAR HIM SAYING
IT EXACTLY THAT WAY.
AN INTERESTING POINT THERE.
DAVID, WE HAVE ALSO BEEN HEARING
FROM THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
DONALD TRUMP RETURNED TO THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL HIMSELF LAST
NIGHT IN PENNSYLVANIA.
AS EXPECTED, HE RAILED AGAINST
THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE SEARCH OF HIS
FLORIDA HOME.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> THE SHAMEFUL RAID AND
BREAK-IN OF MY HOME, MAR-A-LAGO,
WAS A TRAVESTY OF JUSTICE.
THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAVE BECOME VICIOUS
MONSTERS.
THEY'RE TRYING TO SILENCE ME
AND, MORE IMPORTANTLY, THEY ARE
TRYING TO SILENCE YOU, BUT WE
WILL NOT BE SILENCED.
>> THE FBI IS NOT RAIDING
PEOPLE'S HOMES OR SEARCHING
PEOPLE'S HOMES WITH NO LEGAL
BACKING.
THEY WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS TO
GO INTO MAR-A-LAGO, BUT HE IS
MAKING THIS A HUGE ISSUE.
IS IT A GOOD IDEA FOR HIM?
HOW MIGHT THAT IMPACT THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS FOR HIM TO USE
THIS, SORT OF LIKE SAYING, IF IT
HAPPENS TO YOU, IT COULD HAPPEN
TO YOU, EVEN THOUGH THEY DID GO
THROUGH A LEGAL PROCESS?
>> SARA, I THINK LEGALLY IT'S
NOT HELPING PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT
MUCH, BUT POLITICALLY GRIEVANCE
IS PART OF HER BRAND.
AND I DO THINK THE MORE HE CAN
STRETCH THIS OUT, THE MORE HE
CAN GET HIMSELF BACK IN THE NEWS
AS OPPOSED TO OTHER LEADING
REPUBLICAN FIGURES LIKE FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS.
IT DOES HELP HIM AND IT IS WHERE
HE WANTS TO BE.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK OF
SPECIAL MASTERS AND MAGISTRATES
AND WARRANTS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THIS
THING IS FAIRLY SIMPLE.
SIMPLER THAN PRESIDENT TRUMP
WANTS IT TO BE.
THE DOCUMENTS HE HAD BELONG TO
THE PEOPLE OF THE UNITED STATES.
THEY SHOULD BE HOUSED AT THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
LAST YEAR THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES
ASKED FOR THEM BACK.
THEY DIDN'T GET ALL OF THEM
BACK.
SO, OOEBTLY, THEY GOT LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVOLVED.
LAW ENFORCEMENT GOT A WARRANT.
THEY WENT AND RETRIEVED THE
DOCUMENTS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS NOT YET BEEN
CHARGED WITH ANY CRIME.
HE MAY NOT BE CHARGED WITH A
CRIME.
THAT IS THAT.
AS FAR AS WE KNOW, POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES WERE FOLLOWED.
BUT FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
CONTINUE TO GIN THIS UP AS IT'S
ME AGAINST THE WORLD, THEREFORE,
ME AND MY SUPPORTERS AGAINST THE
WORLD, THAT, I THINK, IS WHAT HE
WANTS POLITICALLY.
>> TIM, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
SITUATION AND HOW DONALD TRUMP
IS TRYING TO USE THIS AS A
TALKING POINT IN WHAT MANY THINK
HE'S GOING TO RUN, HOW SHOULD
DEMOCRATS DEAL WITH THIS AND THE
WORDS THAT HE'S USING?
>> I THINK ONE OF THE LESSONS OF
THE TRUMP ERA IS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO AVOID GETTING
SUCKERED INTO SOME OF THESE
DEBATES WITH DONALD TRUMP.
IN A SENSE, GIVE SOME OF HIS
ARGUMENTS A LEGITIMACY, IF EVEN
TAKE THEM SERIOUSLY.
THERE IS NO ARGUMENT.
THERE IS NO DEFENSE FOR HIM
HAVING CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
THERE IS NO DEFENSE FOR HIM
HAVING GOVERNMENT TALKS, AS
DAVID MENTION, AT MAR-A-LAGO.
HE IS GOING TO KEEP SAYING THAT
HE HAD A RIGHT TO -- HE'LL
INVENT RIGHTS, HE'LL INTENT
PRIVILEGES.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
FOCUS ON WHAT MATTERS TO MOST
AMERICANS WHICH IS INFLATION,
THE UNEMPLOYMENT, CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THE DOBBS DECISION AND THE
FACT THAT WOMEN DO NOT HAVE THE
FREEDOMS THEY HAD BEFORE THE
SUPREME COURT'S DOBBS DECISION.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS HAVE OTHER
THINGS TO FOCUS ON AND THEY
REALLY SHOULD TRY TO AVOID GOING
DOWN THE RABBIT HOLE WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP HAS NO INTEREST IN
A REAL NATIONAL DIALOGUE ABOUT
POWER, PRIVILEGE AND THE
PRESIDENCY.
HE ONLY HAS AN INTEREST IN
GETTING POWER HIMSELF AND BEING
PRESIDENT ONCE AGAIN.
>> THE DOJ CERTAINLY LAID OUT TO
THE PUBLIC SOME OF THE DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE THERE, SHOWING FOLDERS
OF CONFIDENTIAL DOCUMENTS THAT
WERE SORT OF OPENED UP SO WE
COULD ALL SEE THAT HE HAD THEM.
SO, THERE IS A LOT TO GO
THROUGH.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE
HEARING A LOT AB